[Music]
[Music]
all right people we are live on YouTube
and Facebook today and joining me is an
author a clinical psychologist and
professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto dr. Jordan
Peterson welcome to the Rubin report
thanks very much
I'm glad we're gonna be able to do this
live because you saved me once because I
was in between studios I had just moved
into this house and and your whole
situation had blown up and everybody was
saying get Peterson on the show and we
did it on Google hangout which is a
little is a little stiff and and you
were pixelated and there were moments of
audio dropouts but yeah I'm not
pixelated and real no you're completely
I'm shocked you seem whole and very
dimensional completely 3-dimensional I
can see the whole thing so I'm glad
we're doing this because I wanted to do
alive I always find that the live
interaction is is better than the online
interaction but also your your whole
situation basically starting in
September when you gave this this talk
you sort of exploded onto the scene is
that is that a fair estimation that's a
fair estimation yeah within I made three
videos yeah of approximately the same
audio quality as our Google hangout I
would say yeah and I did it well to
clarify some things in my own mind but
also as an experiment I suppose I had
had a youtube channel for about three
years and it kept growing you know not
tremendously but by April of last year I
had about a million views on for my for
my lectures right and well that made me
perk up a bit in terms of attention
because a million of anything is a lot
yeah and so I thought well I'll lay this
out on YouTube as an experiment and see
what happened it's like next thing you
know you're all over the place okay so I
want to talk about that lecture
obviously but I thought that the best
way we could start here because you've
done a ton of interviews now and you've
you've been on Sam Harris's podcast
twice you're doing Rogen in a couple
days and you've been on his show before
and you've chatted with a lot of the
same people in this space but I thought
that the best thing we could do to start
is just reset everything because there
because people are very passionate
what you do we're gonna do a Q&A at the
end of this and we already have a whole
queue of questions ready to roll
yeah so just for people that know
nothing about you what would be the
first way do we do we want to just talk
about your academic work or is there
anything about your history childhood
that you think sets sets you up to end
up you know sitting right here no I
think it's I think in large part it's my
academic work I wouldn't say it's the
mainstream academic work I do though I
mean I've done a lot of academic
publishing in scientific journals in the
field of personality and and abnormal
psychology that's pretty normal science
to borrow a phrase from Thomas Kuhn it's
incremental and progressive I've worked
with my students on delineating the
structure of personality more at a more
fine-grained level but I wrote a book in
and published it in 1999 that I worked
on for about 15 years for about two
hours or three hours a day and I was
attempting to understand the underlying
structure of belief systems and to
determine what psychological role they
played because I was interested in the
degree to which people adhere to their
belief systems and there has to be a
psychological reason for that lots of
conflicts are over
not so much economics as the economic
economist claim and the Marxists but
over values and values play a very
important role in in a psychological
ecosystem in a determining role which
was something I was trying to discuss
with Sam Harris but it's a very
difficult discussion yeah but so that
book in that book I analyzed belief
systems like Marxism and like Western
capitalist democracy associated say with
Christianity and then tried to go
underneath that to look at what you
might describe as the mythological sub
structure for me this is how we are in
the world we have an articulated
viewpoint and it's encapsulated in a
dream
personally and culturally so basically
we're at this level so right now
everything we're discussing is sort of
at this level that's articulated the
unspoken piece is all the rest of the
pieces that that sort of put that all
together that we don't really talk about
well that we don't really understand
that's it's like imagine I think of it
this way is there's a domain that you
could consider known explored and that
domain technically is where when you do
something you get the outcome you want
that's really the technical definition
of it and that's a that's a definition
of a kind of knowledge it's practical
knowledge right I know what I'm doing if
when I do it what I predict what I want
to have happen happens right and then I
can feel comfortable there because I've
mastered the situation I'm them and and
and I'm not in danger so that's one
domain of reality and another domain is
the unknown and unknown is symbolically
it's often nature as opposed to culture
say but it's it's more complex than that
because the unknown can manifest itself
at any moment when when you act in a
certain way and you desire an outcome
and that outcome doesn't happen then now
no one manifests itself and now unknown
is you could call it transcendent in
some sense because it's beyond what we
know obviously and it's also
unbelievably complicated and we have one
part of our nervous system so to speak
that deals with the realm of the known
and the other part of our nervous system
mostly that deals with negative emotion
deals with unknown and it's negative
emotion and fantasy so you might say
well there's the known world
then there's the unknown world but
there's a bridge between the two and
that bridge is the dream or mythology
it's something like that is metaphor
that's another way of thinking about it
and it's sort of half known and half
unknown it's this it's this amorphous
bridging point and our knowledge
structures are articulated knowledge
structures are embedded in that dream so
here's an example yeah Western
democracies are predicated on the idea
that individuals have an intrinsic
value essentially intrinsic value before
God because it's an equal value
everyone's equal before the law even
though we're very unequal as beings we
have this mythological idea essentially
it's not rational precisely it's more
like an axiomatic assumption it's
something like that that there's
something intrinsically valuable about
each person and it is something you can
prove it's something you have to assume
and then go from there now the reason we
assume that is very complicated I think
it's it's not arbitrary so one of the
things I was trying to figure out in
this book called maps of meaning was
there was this huge fight going on
between the Marxists the Communists and
the Western world and one way of
thinking about that is that it's a clash
of opinions it's just a matter of
opinion so I was trying to find out if
there was something at the base of
Western culture that might be considered
more than mere opinion more than mere
rational opinion grounded say well what
I think is grounded in this dreamlike
process but then grounded in biology
grounded in the body grounded in
evolutionary psychology grounded in our
entire biological past and so I've been
trying to make a case for the
evolutionary psychology of religious
propositions that's one way of thinking
about it so this this bridge that you're
talking about between these two worlds
how much of that bridge is really just
the the biggest existential questions
that there are well it is that because
one of the things I've noticed as a
clinical psychologist too when when you
deal with really serious issues say uh
issues of good and evil and you might
think well do you deal with issues of
good and evil as a clinical psychologist
in the answer to that is in serious
cases almost inevitably so with
post-traumatic stress disorder for
example if it's a soldier who's
experienced it or for that matter of
civilian it's not often so much because
of what happened to them although that
can happen it's because of what they did
they see them doing something say on the
battlefield or or in normal life that
they cannot believe they did it's it's
so far outside of their self-concept it
it opens them up to a different
dimension of reality and I would say
that dimension is the dimension of
evil not ya meaning that they killed
someone or that they made a mistake or
so that they're basically sort of
turning it on themselves and that's well
maybe they killed someone in a
particularly brutal manner and enjoyed
it for example you know or maybe they
went into my lie you know you remember
in Vietnam where they shot up the entire
village mean you don't know what you'd
be like on a battlefield
yeah but you wouldn't be like you are
sitting here right you'd be a different
thing you'd be a different creature and
I mean one example is that you know men
often rape in battle but sex is very
seldom a public display although it can
be in battle well to my way of thinking
that means there's a whole different
neural circuit involved under those
conditions it's much more brutal and you
know you have a self-concept imagine
that you're like a Mid American guy you
know a young kid basically get shipped
off somewhere and do something
absolutely barbaric how do you fit that
into your conception of the world one of
the things you do with people who have
post-traumatic stress disorder is guide
them to find a philosophy of good and
evil because otherwise they can't orient
themselves again in the world yeah so so
they have to become more sophisticated
and really they have to become more
metaphysically sophisticated and it's
very common in my experience for an
encounter with malevolence and so I
would describe malevolence as the desire
to hurt for the sake of the hurt right
as a as an art really and it's often an
encounter with malevolence that breaks
people I had a client at one point I'll
say she was in college she was bullied
very badly by two kids that were out to
get her and the she was so unable to
cope with conceptualizing what they were
doing because it was one of them had
asked her out and she decided no and he
decided he would make her life miserable
and she was a naive girl which which
matters right because you're more likely
to get post-traumatic stress disorder if
you're naive and the malevolence that
the two displayed tossed her into a
psychotic break and that's not so
uncommon so when you talk about serious
things in psycho
therapy you end up speaking what's
essentially a religious language the
language of the war between good and
evil it's a huge part of it so do you
think that right now in 2017 as we stand
here on
I think today's may fit that that we're
at a strange place related to both of
these worlds you're talking about
because I sense that what's happening
here is that we don't trust the news
sources anymore in the way that we used
to we don't trust the politicians in the
way we used to we are all catering
information to ourselves online all of
this stuff so that our known world what
we would describe is this world right
here that that I think is starting to
fray a little bit do you agree with that
yes yes and what do you think that means
for our ability to cope with the other
world well part of part of what makes
people peaceful because we like to think
we're peaceful but we're not were
neither peaceful nor anxiety-free
in fact I would say that the normative
human being is just as much terrified
and murderous as calm and collected
everything has to be right for you to be
calm and collected now the reason you
and I can sit here and talk is because
we share a very large number of
assumptions and so I don't really see
you I see this facade for this time that
you're that you're manifesting out of
politeness and because you're socialized
yeah and you see that of me and that
means that we're two primates who can
sit here and have a discussion without
it breaking down into anything
resembling say violence right but very
quickly you could whip out a knife and
the whole game would kill yes yes how
quickly well my facade would disappear
there's a fantastic scene in in us in a
book by Dostoyevsky called the possessed
or the devil's which is a great book by
the way it it's one of the books that
outlines where we're headed I would say
even though it was written more than a
hundred years ago because it's about
people who are possessed by an ideology
that's very much like the social justice
ideology that's emerged again there's
one scene in there I think the
character's name is stavrogin
but he's breaking down because these
belief systems are starting to shift
around and he isn't sure how to
conceptualize himself and at one point I
may have the character's name wrong he
grabs he goes into this club I know it's
a like an elite aristocratic Club light
and there's an old general sitting in
there and he grabs him by the nose and
pulls him out onto the street
which you know in in one sense it's not
a particularly brutal thing to do but
it's such a violation it was such a
violation of the social norm that it
just caused absolute outrage and that
that's a good example it's like I would
all I wouldn't have to be particularly
different I wouldn't have to pull out a
knife in order to destabilize the
conversation right there's lots of
subtly strange things that you could do
or that I could do that would put a real
undercurrent into the conversation you
can experience that sometimes if you
ever happen to talk to someone who's
psychopathic and you get a sense of that
that's actually what what they're like
there's videos online of Paul Bernardo
and I would recommend that people take a
look at those because they'll give you
some sense of what can be bubbling
underneath the surface yeah so part of
the reason that belief systems regulate
people's emotions aggression and fear
let's say and discuss many many motions
is because we act them out in the world
and as long as we're both acting out the
same set of assumptions then we can get
what we want from each other because we
can predict each other's behavior and we
can cooperate easily we can even compete
because we know the rules of competition
but if that shared structure starts to
fall apart then I don't know what you're
going to be like so that that I think
gets to what my question is and I sense
that that's starting to fall apart I
think the basic societal norms the way
we react to each other it has a lot to
do with social media and how we you know
the outrage machine and how we destroy
each other and judge each other and I
see some of this now leaking
out into an tyfa violins and that you
know that the trust in our institutions
is so low that i think all of the things
that we've been basing our democracy on
for the last certainly for the at least
the last fifty years they seem to be
frayed right now and i'm wondering as
you're saying this what would you it
almost seems be you'd only have to give
it a a light tap to really unfurl some
well i think you know a nice economic
collapse like 2008 would do it and i you
know i think that's the sort of thing
that happened in Nazi Germany in the in
the 20s and the 30s you know it wasn't
just brutalized men back from World War
one and it wasn't just the the conflict
between communism and fascism and
communism was a real threat right
because the Russian Revolution had just
occurred it was also an absolute
economic collapse I mean we can't even
really imagine that and it would be in
some sense far worse today because the
Machine is more in complex and and
people are farther away from primary
sources of food for example so yeah we
could get unlucky and and and and in the
present state of chaos the dawning chaos
then things could fall apart badly I'm
curious when you when you first were
writing the book and as you said it was
over the course of many years and yes
many hours a day did you sort of see
this leading to kind of where we are
right now like right now that you're
kind of in this in a very intimate way
your whole life has sort of led to this
and we're going to get to you know these
crazy people that are protesting you and
all that sort of stuff but did you sense
that if this thing didn't get corrected
that we would end up well at that point
I didn't I it's a complicated question I
didn't really foresee the degree to
which ideas like equity for example
equality of outcome would come roaring
back that's really quite shocking to me
I still don't know what to make of that
and it's happening so rapidly that I
that I can't hardly believe it and with
so little opposition I did think though
and that was from reading Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky and Solzhenitsyn I supposed
to some degree that without the proper
cornerstone in place the bill
can stay up and that was Nietzsche's
point about the death of Christianity
right he believed firmly that because
Christianity had been criticized in some
sense out of existence that the
foundations have been taken out from
underneath the culture and that it was
going to either fall or rigidify or fall
and rigidify
I mean you might think about those as
responses on the left and on the right
and that struck me as very credible
because one of the things Nietzsche said
was that what you don't understand about
Western civilization is that it's a
coherent metaphysics it's predicated on
the idea of the existence of God and
then of the also the Incarnation let's
say and those are the dreamlike
foundations of the entire building and
if you remove those then it becomes a
matter of opinion and in some sense
that's what the post modernists are
claiming and that it's just a matter of
opinion or they say it's a matter of
power because that's a huge claim on
their part so I've had this discussion
this very point with a couple people
some who are believers like Dennis
Prager and some who are not believers
like Sam Harris do you think if I go
with you on the on the premise of what
you're saying within that system
I assume you believe that the individual
themselves could be a non-believer in a
perfectly productive part of society
right it's just that the only for a time
really yeah I think that you know it's
like it's like we're living in the
corpse of a whale you know there's lots
to eat but that's because there was a
whale and once we eat the whole whale
then well there's not going to be much
left people like Sam Harris and Richard
Dawkins they assume that the natural
person is the civilized creature that
you see before you in a discussion like
this but I don't believe that I think
that people are far crazier and far more
destructive and and far greater as well
then the typical rationalist approach
rationality is a surface facade that's
all and the idea that people will
eventually be rational it's much more
likely that they will be irrational than
rationally you could say for example
that
Catholicism let's say for all its
irrationality was as rational as people
can get if you remove that level of the
irrationality that structural say then
everything falls apart and people get so
irrational you can't believe it
not more rational you know because they
like Harrison and his crowd think that
we were superstitious for thousands of
years kind of savage and and and and
superstitious and then all of a sudden
the Enlightenment came along in the
scientific revolution and poof we got
rational and since then things have been
good and that's not how it looks to me
at all I don't I don't buy that I think
that our rationality as I said already
our rationality even our science is
nested inside this larger metaphysical
structure this is also something that
Carl Jung would be an advocate of that
there's a irrational pragmatic I would
say evolutionarily determined ethic
underneath this rationality and when it
goes then all that rationality goes to
so yes you can be a non-believer but the
funny thing about that is too you can't
be a non-believer in your action you see
because Harris's metaphysics is
fundamentally Christian so he acts out a
Christian metaphysics but he says well I
don't believe it it's like well yeah you
do because you're acting it out you just
say you don't believe it believe me you
mean that what do you mean he's acting
acting it out like what for example
well it doesn't rob banks doesn't kill
people doesn't rape doesn't murder you
know mean we look in good knee in in in
in crime and punishment for example so
you think I mean when you don't do those
things basically the underpinning of it
even though I think I certainly I can't
speak for salmon you guys have had by
the way regardless of where we get with
this you guys have had I think two great
conversations one where you didn't quite
get there but one where you've you've
come together and I suspect you both
really relish in that right I mean at
the end of the day this is someone that
you respect whether you dismiss it
oh no you know not look I mean yeah I
just think you need to preface cuz so at
each other's throats all the time
when I saw two people that I respect
just disagreeing on things but really
trying to get there I thought this is
good yeah there's a certain amount of
people that rep you know that want you
guys to yeah other parties well there's
a good case to be made for atheism I
mean let's let's make no no bones about
it
I actually think it's an easier case to
make than the alternative because you
could say in some sense there's been 300
400 years of brilliant scientists who've
been doing nothing but laying the
foundation for a non objective empirical
atheism so it's an unbelievably powerful
argument but it's not going to lead to
the to the rule of rationality see I
don't believe that I don't believe that
because you think anything could get you
there do you think somebody could lay
out a case that could eventually turn
you on this the same way you would want
someone like Sam to come around to what
you're saying do you think that that I
don't have any realm of I can't see how
because it's it's not like I haven't
thought these things through I mean I am
a scientist you know I understand the
scientific worldview in fact everything
that I am saying and thinking about
religion is nested inside an
evolutionary viewpoint an evolutionarily
an evolutionary biology viewpoint and an
evolutionary psychology viewpoint so I
do believe there's a fundamental
contrast between a Darwinian worldview
in a Newtonian worldview which is the
worldview that i think sam harris and
his crowd basically have he didn't agree
with that but and it's complicated
yeah but but see I guess in some sense
I'm more romantic in temperament than
Sam and I think then his followers too
and because of that I can see the
irrational and malevolent side of human
beings I believe much more clearly than
they can and I also think I have far
more experience with that sort of thing
yeah so do you think that so we don't
want to get too lost here so we'll try
to wrap it up here because there's so
much I want to do with you here
so let's say earth is crumbling we have
two ships we're going to send the people
that believe what you are saying here
basically that we need this sort of
religious underpinning and then the the
Dawkins Sam people they're going to take
there
people you're going to take your under
people were going to go to two different
planets and set things up the way they
should be
you know blank slate for for each well I
guess the part that I would struggle
with here is to understand how that how
their ship lands they're rooted in
science and in in basic liberalism and
and acceptance of others and all that
how that society would not flourish from
them from the base level if we could
just reset now I think you could make a
great argument that we can't do it here
because there's just so much history
here and all that stuff but if we were
just resetting on another place why
could we not do it that way and have it
work well first of all you know there's
an assumption that science and the
scientific worldview in some sense has
one no and and because it's so
self-evident let's say because of what
it can produce that people just will
accept it move forward with it but I'm
not sure about that either I mean I
think there's a strong anti science
movement afloat now I don't think
there's any reason to assume that a
scientific attitude of that sort would
be stable I mean it it's only 300 years
old
for I mean people don't like it when I
say that because okay fine you can chase
it back to some degree to the ancient
Greeks you know barely right but really
it was Newton and bacon and and
Descartes and and that's not very long
ago and we take it for granted but
there's anti science movements popping
up well look the whole debate over
biology to some degree yeah is
profoundly an anti science movement and
and not unconsciously so consciously so
yeah very good yes very good answering
so yeah so so I I don't think that
there's any reason to assume something
like that would be stable there's no
evidence that it's stable let's say
where where is there is evidence for the
stability of cultures that were
non-scientific for thousands of years
millions of years for that matter at
least hundreds of thousands of years
yeah so there was a lot of war and death
involved in those cultures too but
that's yes that's what I guess that
would be your argument is that this is
just the nature of this battle between
these these two worlds that we live in
yeah well you know the other thing that
often happens with with with
Hawkins and Harrison and and their crew
is that they attribute war and conflict
to religious motivations you know I find
that quite interesting because first of
all chimpanzees go to war so you know we
could just lay that right on the table
and say well so much for the religious
theory they're territorial we're
territorial you could consider religious
sentiment as an aspect of territoriality
but the fundamental motivation for the
battle is territorial and that's
grounded it like you can see that in
animals always so that was only
discovered you know the chimps went to
war in about mid 70s and and and Goodall
suppressed it for quite a while because
she thought maybe she had warped the
chimpanzees by by provisioning them and
so that they were manifesting abnormal
behavior but they were studied for quite
a while and they do do raiding and there
and they'll wipe out another colony no
problem and brutally they seem to have
absolutely no inhibitions on their
aggression whatsoever they'll tear them
into pieces and chimpanzees are about
six times as strong as an adult male
they're super strong and so when they
let loose they're vicious with no
control and so unless you're willing to
attribute religious sentiment to the
chimpanzees which I think you could to
some degree by the way how do we make
that jump for a chimpanzee well because
the precursors to religious belief are
in place so for example animals organize
themselves into a hierarchy you could
call it a dominance hierarchy but it's
not exactly the right way to
conceptualize it because dominance
sounds like power right and that's sort
of the social justice warrior
postmodernist claim that all hierarchies
are based on power but Fran's de Waal
who's a dutch anthropologist who studied
chips for a long time has noted that the
brutal chimp dictatorship tends to be
unstable and end in a very violent mean
manner well so if you're a brutal chimp
leader and you're always tormenting
everyone and you don't do any reciprocal
grooming and you don't have any friends
then one day two chimps who are nicely
bonded together three-quarters your size
wait and ambush you and tear you into
pieces and so one of the things do all
has noted is that the stable chimpanzee
troops tend to have a leader
that's quite pro-social lot of friends a
lot of social bonds a lot of mutual
grooming and so you could see even there
imagine that imagine that there are sets
of hierarchies among chimpanzees and
there are different principles of
leadership at the top then you could
imagine a competition across time which
principle of leadership is going to
produce the most stable and functional
chimpanzee hierarchy well that is
exactly what does happen and so there's
there's some there's some shape that the
top of the hierarchy starts to check to
take and you could think about that as
the beginnings of an ideal right and
then it's even more complicated than
that because let's say you get a stable
hierarchy set up and then this is what
happens in human beings it doesn't
happen in chimps or it does but only to
a limited degree you get a stable
hierarchy set up and then there's some
pattern of behavior that emerges that
reliably moves men to the top of that ok
they leave more offspring so what
happens is that the male dominance our
male hierarchy forget about dominance
the male hierarchy becomes a selection
mechanism it promotes men to the upper
ranks and then the women peel off the
top because we know that human females
do that chimpanzee females don't they're
promiscuous mater's the dominant males
are more likely to mate with the females
but that's because they chase the
subordinates away it's not because the
females are choosy so the reason I'm
telling you this it's really important
because imagine that there's a reliable
pattern of behavior that will move you
up a male hierarchy across time what
that means is that men over time have
become biologically adapted to that
pattern as the hierarchy is there it's
stable it exists across millions of
years and so it acts as a selection
mechanism by promoting men and so the
men who have the genes that are most
likely to get them promoted put those
genes forward and so we get more like
the group ideal as we progress through
time both biologically and culturally
and we then we also start to articulate
that group ideal and that's partly what
a religion does when it when it's coming
up with the idea of an ideal so I was
listing some of the I've been wrestling
with this idea because I'm going to give
some biblical lectures starting on May
16th and so I've been starting to think
about conceptualizations of God for
example one of the things that's very
interesting about the Old Testament is
that there's a there's a distinction
made between countries that rule by the
ruler who's God and countries that are
ruled by God who's not the ruler
okay so strip it for a minute of its
religious language and imagine this
instead imagine that what we consider
God is the abstraction of the ideal by
which people have to orient themselves
to produce a functional society it's an
abstraction right it's just sort of the
the basic underlying truth of how we are
able to function as a group of people
yes properly and you can't identify it
with any one person because when you
identify it with the person then the
system gets corrupted because the person
gets inflated let's say this would be
like the Pharaoh basic yes exactly like
precisely like that that that's exactly
that that's the canonical story in the
Old Testament yeah is the Pharaoh is the
earthly ruler who demands everything
that you should provide to God what's
God well we'll speak about it from an
evolutionary psychology perspective God
is the idea of the abstract ideal and
you separate it out from from the actual
ruler just like in in our society the
idea of sovereignty is abstracted from
the president right the president comes
and goes the sovereignty of the
president remains the sovereignty of the
president is a very abstract idea
because it's disembodied right it's
disembodied now how we were chimps for
God's sake how long do you think it took
us to figure out how to disembody the
idea of sovereignty from the individual
man it was like well it was it was maybe
up until
maybe it took us till 150,000 years ago
to start to start formulating that you
know within some articulated way in some
abstract way I think we could recognize
it before them and the way you recognize
it is through admiration right if you
meet someone that you admire there's
someone you want to imitate and what it
is imagine this pattern that will move
you up the hierarchy and then you see
people who manifest different elements
of it and you see someone who manifests
an element that you don't have and
something in your response to that with
admiration it's unconscious right
because it pulls you towards them it's
not voluntary you see without really
with kids a lot when they when they
hero-worship someone and start to
imitate them right no but but the same
thing happens throughout culture yeah
you could probably make an interesting
argument related to Trump with this
because it was like some people's I
think subconsciously although some we're
consciously saw him and they said wow he
says whatever he wants yeah and they
love that and then you could also argue
the reverse some people saw him saying
whatever he wants and they thought this
is this is the end of civilization right
since this is some monster for
civilization so that does sort also go
to I guess self-deception and how we all
are viewing things differently
constantly all the time well there's a
bunch of ways that that you can bias
your information in take let's say now
what should happen is roughly speaking I
guess is that you have a field of
information let's say it's behavioral
information so it's information that
would be relevant to how you conduct
yourself which isn't the same as factual
information which is another mistake
that I think Harris makes what you want
is an unbiased sample of that you can't
understand all of it because it's too
complex wait wait let's just back up for
a sec you have to be clear so that I
think everyone would understand what
factual information is what's the other
part then give me an example of the
other part the other part is what makes
you admire someone so it's just the it's
the innate feeling sort well it's it's
it's what you get when you go to a movie
say that's that's an animated movie we
talked about that a little bit with
Pinocchio for example is that what's
being presented there are descriptions
of patterns of behavior they're not you
they're fact like but the reason that
they're different than facts is because
you can immediately act
out you can't act out of fact it's like
so imagine that you're standing in front
of the field if you adopted Harris's
point of view as far as I can tell the
field would tell you how to walk through
it but it doesn't it offers you an
infinite number of ways to walk through
it and then how you walk through it
depends on your value system it depends
on what you want that's the thing that's
where values enter it you're going to
walk through the field towards your goal
and your goal is something you value and
that's built right into our perception
you can't even look at the world without
a goal because there's too much of the
world and if you don't have a goal then
you don't know what to look out it'll
just be chaotic or meaningless either
one of those too overwhelming or
meaningless and so the the the value
system is built into the perceptions now
that brings us back to the bias issues
that when you when you look at a field
of behavioral information let's say or
even factual information for that matter
your temperament is going to screen a
lot of it out for you and that's good
because otherwise you'd be overwhelmed
but let's say you're a person who's not
creative and that generally tends to
make people more conservative anything
that has to do with aesthetics
generally speaking isn't going to
glimmer for you right it's not going to
attract your interest now if you're next
to virt then social things are attract
your interest and if you're agreeable
person then things about relationships
will attract your interest if you're
disagreeable it's more likely to be
about machines and things so but that's
all happening before you think now
there's feedback loops of course but it
happens before you think you're carving
out a niche in the world and there's
lots of different ways you can be in the
world so that's one form of bias and you
see this input in in the realm of
politics because we know for example
that you can predict people's political
beliefs if you know their temperament
and quite well so if people are high in
trade openness which is creativity
creativity and interest in abstract
ideas roughly speaking and low in
conscientiousness especially orderliness
you're going to be a liberal you're
going to lean to the left you're going
to be a liberal that the politically
correct types are different
and if you're low in openness and high
in conscientiousness especially
orderliness you're going to be a
conservative and the relationship is
actually quite tight if you just look at
how people vote the relationship isn't
that powerful but if you do a detailed
analysis of their beliefs a conservative
versus liberal the amount of political
belief the temperament accounts for it
goes way up do you think people can
change
those factors about them so if you're
any of those personality types that you
laid out and you really saw it you know
someone's listening to you right this
second at home and goes yeah I'm really
I'm one of these this fits me but I
really do want to change my thinking I
want to be a little more open or a
little more you know accessible to the
human interaction or care more about art
or just any of you you can either take
it to as little ya know degree as you
want do you think people can really
fundamentally alter that in adulthood
yeah you could practice so the thing is
your personality isn't just this
abstract thing you carry around with you
that's like part of an ethereal spirit
you know that you can just flip like
that right it's built into your body so
for example if you're an orderly person
and say that that's been there since you
were tiny person you've built micro
habits of orderliness into your world
and into your body because as you
practice something you build neural
circuits that underpin that ability and
so by the time you're 30 and you're an
orderly person you've got 30 years of
being an orderly person it's like now
you might want to get the orderly person
to relax a little bit right because
they're orderly they want everything
where it should be they don't want the
concepts touching they want them
separate they or you take a disorderly
person you want them to be orderly well
you have to train them in some sense
like you train a two-year-old
you know it's like well you have to
clean up your room well I don't know how
to do that
well then you decompose it even further
maybe this I'm speaking as a behavior
therapist you're a mess let's start by
by ordering your world a little bit try
making your bed every day for a week
that's it that's what you have to do
this week and you know you think well
anybody could do that it's like no they
can't I had a client at one point um he
he was very disorderly he had a dream he
just had a child and he dreamt that a
lightning bolt came into the room and
was bouncing around the room and we
talked over that a bit and it turned out
that he was afraid of the potential of
the child he was afraid he would be a
bad and that's what the the ball of
lightning essentially represented and
this this immense potential that the
child represented it was an archetypal
dream and he was afraid that he wouldn't
be a good father and he had reason to be
afraid that he wouldn't be a good father
is a very disorderly person and also
working against himself
um we agreed that he would vacuum I
believe it was his bedroom twice for the
week and he came back the first week and
he said that he put the vacuum cleaner
was one of those uprights in his doorway
you know like so was leaning against the
door jamb and he stepped over it all
week to get back and forth into his room
I never vacuumed yeah Wow no kidding Wow
absolutely
and so you can change your personality
but you have to understand that it's
it's like I said it's not an ethereal
spirit if you want to be more open you
could start reading more books but
that's hard and you probably won't do it
you can start listening to a broader
variety of music you could expose
yourself to art museums but you also
don't have the knack for it right so
that doesn't glimmer for you and if
you're an introvert you can learn
extroverted skills but the probability
that's going to make you extroverted is
very low you're still going to be tired
out when you interact with people too
much whereas an extrovert is energized
by by a social interaction does it
depress you in a certain way that we
don't focus on this stuff enough just
the basics of what what makes us real
what makes our desire to interact with
another person and and be real and
really try to get to some truth we spend
almost no time on that yeah I think
that's why people are responding to you
people you know for the bulk of it I see
people that really like you and admire
you then I see these is the certain
group of let's say intolerant people
that don't we'll get to them in just a
sec but does that does that depress you
or does that inspire you just that
concept well a lot of what I'm talking
about right now is pretty new you know
this psychologists have only settled on
a reasonably stable personality model in
the last 40 years and and started to
really flesh it out I would say over
since about 1995 something like that hmm
so it's pretty new and the work relating
personality to political belief is even
newer than that and we haven't begun to
grapple with its full implications I
wouldn't say because we tend to think
and that this would be part of the
Enlightenment rationality is that you
look dispassionately at the set of facts
you abstract out a rational conclusion
from that and you believe it and the
thing is that isn't how it works now
it's kind of how it works but we'll get
to that what happens instead is you look
at a field of facts that's so broad you
can't see the edges yeah and then you
you filter that a priority with your
camerman so some things it's like
imagine there's a bright light and then
there's a black curtain in front of it
and there's holes in the curtain and
light shines through well depending on
who you are those holes are going to be
in a different in a different place so
the thing is is that the facts that
present themselves to you will look
different than the facts that present
themselves to someone else
now you can overcome that to some degree
that's why free speech is so important
as far as I'm concerned because you're
going to look at the world your way
honestly and it can be different than
mine it even if I look at it honestly so
but then we can talk and I can listen to
you and I can alter my preconceptions to
some degree by that exchange of ideas
like it's hard because you unfold the
idea and you blast it to me and then I
have to unfold it into action and and
into the restructuring of my perceptions
it's very very complicated after if we
have a profound conversation I'm
allowing little parts of me to die and
new parts to grow on a constant basis so
it's effortful but it's one of the
mechanisms that we've evolved to
overcome the limitations of the
individual human being we filter
information we're lazy in our habits
we're not good at thinking which is an
internal argument let's say very few
people can do that they don't fit they
don't think
what they do is ideas appear to them and
they believe them that's what happens
thinking is different thinking is saying
okay well here's a set of ideas and
here's another set of ideas all right so
let's put them in combat and see what
emerges well that's very very hard often
you have to do that by writing yeah and
we need that more than anything else
it's why as I'm sitting here I'm trying
it's actually I think it comes innately
to me but I'm trying to be as open as I
can to your ideas hearing what I think
makes make sense trying to respond with
questions that make sense and understand
your line of thinking and let you lay
out examples that make sense so that my
audience that maybe doesn't follow all
of it can get all those pieces but
that's the dance we're not doing very
well as a society right now well they're
they see the post modernists believe
that hierarchies only based on power and
power is only based on exploitation so
this is the Marxist this is this is
specifically the postmodern gas-like
they're nested in Marxism and the reason
for that is post-modernism doesn't tell
you what to do and you have to know what
to do even if you're a post modernist
you can't just do nothing you have to
act something out or you just sit there
and die no because inaction is not good
for people so you have to there has to
be an ethic but post modernists are
basically aimed at destroying any ethic
especially any transcending it
transcendent ethic that would unite
people okay wait I like that so they
basically blew up the archetype because
they're only focused on the power
principle yes is that yes yes yes yes
that that's that's that's part of it
power and oppression you see so for
someone like Derrida the only reason you
have a category system rough roughly
speaking the only reason you have a
category system is to exclude some
things from it for your purposes now
there's truth in that because every
category excludes but the reason it's
not true is because there's actually
such a thing a as the real world and be
as competence and so well and not just
competence I should add another thing to
that there's there's competence both
socially and naturalistically so one of
the postmodernist claims this is really
important to understand
because they got something right they
got the same thing right that artificial
intelligence researchers ran into in the
1960s when they were trying to make
robots so what they first assumed was
that there's the world man it's just
sitting there all you have to do is look
at the thing and you see it simple
what's hard is to figure out how to
maneuver in the world so they started
building robots that they tried to start
building robots that could see and act
in the world and then they found out
that seeing was way harder than anybody
had ever possibly imagined that you
probably even need a body to see which
Rodney Brooks figured that out who is an
MIT roboticist he invented the Roomba by
the way yeah so meaning that just
putting a set of optic whatever in the
robot that in and of itself is not
enough to see you don't in the authentic
way not at all well because partly what
you're doing really when you're seeing
is mapping the world onto your action in
fact there are connections from your
eyes that go directly to your motor
cortex they bypass your conscious vision
so for example when you look at that cup
your eyes make your hands prepare to do
this because you say well that's an
empirical object it's a cup but that
isn't what your brain thinks your brain
thinks no that's a thing to drink from
right so it that's it's fundamental
see here here's another example of that
it's kind of strange
why are a beanbag in a stump both chairs
they share no objective features in
common except size yeah well the answer
is because you can sit on them and so a
lot of our categories are of that sort
they're not a they're not they're not
empirical categories they're functional
categories and so when you look at the
world if you don't have a body you can't
segregate it into functional categories
okay so that was called partly that was
called the frame problem too many things
to look at how do you choose no one
knows the answer to that is you evolve
in a Darwinian sense over it's billions
of years in a trial-and-error fashion
figuring out how to map this
exceptionally complex reality onto a
body that can survive and propagate
that's that's true basically so that
basically evolution led us to the point
where with no thinking and
in any way I can out of the corner of my
mind see this know what it is know that
there's some liquid in there that I'm
going to drink it I will feel satiated
and that that really is just the
darwinian yes well so so there's a
famous experiment called the visual
cliff so you do it with babies and so
you take surface here and a surface here
about say this high and you put a pane
of glass over the the hole in the middle
then you see if you get the baby to
crawl across the visual cliff well they
won't do it because they don't see the
floor and a piece of glass they see a
falling off place so and they directly
see the falling off place they don't see
the hole and think I'm going to fall
therefore I shouldn't they see it as a
falling off place their body sees it
which is and then it produces an emotion
the eyes map right on to the emotion and
stop the child we do that with snakes
too and with fire and various Oh with
sexual stimuli
you know we there you don't need thought
it the eyes map engine they map right
onto your borrowed I'm gonna give you
some more water right now because I can
sense that perhaps you're thirsty and I
know that I was closer thank you this
and you were closer to your time yeah
well we take all that for granted so the
AI people came up against this problem
it's almost impossible to see the world
because it's too complex well the the
postmodernists to the degree that they
have something credible to say came
across the same problem in textual
analysis they thought well there's an
endless number of ways to interpret a
Shakespearean play and that that's true
there's an infant on your infinite
number of ways you could interpret it so
then they said well there's no canonical
interpretation there's no correct
interpretation so then in some sense
what are we doing well then the answer
came which is the wrong answer well
we're basically playing power games to
establish ourselves in the world and and
all of our interpretations are only in
service of that okay so why is that
wrong well first of all we aren't only
playing power games so that's where the
Marxism creeps in because you know Marx
thought economics drove every
and the postmodernist power is just
sleight-of-hand economics okay so that
isn't all that really the same same
thing yeah new language same thing
allowed them to play the same game after
the economics game became to self
evidently corrupt so they said well
we're just playing this power game but
the same thing is that's not right and
it's also the interpretations aren't
arbitrary so you say well there's an
infinite number of ways to interpret
this room yes but there's a finite
number of ways that will enable you to
make your desires manifest in this room
a very finite number of ways and those
desires are constrained biologically to
begin with so you're a limited perceiver
you come in here if the capacity to turn
the world into a functional entity built
into you so and then there's another so
that's a big constraint man so if you're
if you're analyzing Macbeth you might
say well what could you say about
Macbeth you could never stop talking
about Macbeth what do you want to do as
a reader you want to extract out
something from it that enables you to
behave in a way that gives you a better
grip on the world so you're you're more
skillful in dealing with the world but
but more than that you have to be more
skillful in a way that other people also
allow or even better support and admire
so you're constrained by the world like
if I want that water I have to go like
this right so I can't wish it here I
can't use the other side of my hand this
is it this is the interpretation that
would bring me water right now I can't
grab your water and swill it down either
because I mean I could but that would be
rude right right so so and you know
norms around food sharing for example
are very precise right we could also
dive into an interesting discussion of
about freewill here but we'll put that
aside yeah yeah what we can have we can
talk about that you um so I have to come
up with an interpretation of the world
that functions for me it has to function
for me in a way that doesn't interfere
with my function tomorrow or next week
or next year so that's a tough one man
yeah and then it has to function so that
other people will cooperate and compete
with me in a peaceful way around those
interpretations or otherwise I it's not
going to be good for me so there is a
very large number of potential
interpretations but what the post
modernists will grapple with is that
that doesn't mean the sphere of coherent
interpretations is infinite it isn't
it's because we're embodied because
we're social because there's a world
around us those limit what we can do so
really in a certain way they're trying
to they're trying to destroy the very
structure that has enabled us to
function in society right I mean would
that be the end argument here that
whatever absolutely what they're doing
is I mean they're taking a hatchet
basically to the root of the tree that
that humanity has built because yes
right there trying to under they're
trying to basically destroy the
underpinnings oh well they're they're
actually doing that consciously to some
degree like it's there in Derrida now
you might say well if you took 15 social
justice warriors could you really say
that any of them are consciously trying
to undermine Western civilization and I
would say no 90% of the time they're
regular people
I completely agree that but I have good
intentions I think most do you grant
them that that the average person that's
in this has good intent grant unders
I don't grant that to anyone right so
it's not that I would single them out
necessarily okay it's it's very hard to
have good intentions people say they
have good intentions but the world is a
harsh place it is a very harsh place and
it's very difficult for people not to be
resentful and bitter and often for good
reason like seriously good reason you
know they they had a catastrophic
childhood you know they've got two or
three ill relatives there on their
employment situation is dismal they have
a drug and alcohol problem it's like
things are rough well so they're bitter
about that they're resentful and they're
hurt and they doubt the utility of
existence and to the degree that all of
those things are true then they don't
have good intentions because how you
can't under those circumstances you're
driven by rage and and and the often the
desire for vengeance yeah and I actually
like the way you split that because I
usually say that they that most of them
have good intentions but that does add a
little subtext to it
that that is an important piece yeah
well there's good good intentions are
there yeah people spread out on across
the whole spectrum you know I mean and
certainly the case that normal people in
their burdened lives do heroic things
regularly they go to work in the morning
you know and and they do their their
difficult or dull job and they do it
credibly and they do it mostly honestly
and so hooray
you know so I'm not doubting the good
side of people but I I'm always aware of
the other side and I think you have far
more respect for people if you if you
know about the other side because if
you're just good well you know you're
just running on good yeah a naive person
is sort of like that but someone who's
been fully stretched out in some sense
you know so you meet someone who you
know is a monster but controls usually
himself but sometimes herself you have a
lot more respect for that person they've
got that danger lurking right underneath
the surface and whenever you meet
someone like that you know it you don't
mess with them you know it they
broadcast it and so there are people for
whom that capacity for violence is very
close to the surface now often
especially if they're civilized they
really keep that under control and they
also channel it into authority right so
but it's much better to know it's there
because you you have more respect for
yourself that way to you're not as
careless with yourself if you know that
there's something terrible that could
come out that's lurking underneath the
surface yeah well you're not parenting
you're also granting them the very
capacity that you want within yourself
doesn't mean you're as equally as
damaged or as intended as they are but
right you're looking at yourself you're
looking at them through the same prism
that yes you'd want to look at yourself
through yes yeah yeah that's interesting
well listen we could do we could do five
hours here easily and I clearly have no
need for these notes but because I know
that the everyone wants to ask you
questions I just want to do ten minutes
on one one thing and then we're going to
jump to the to the audience here so I
just want to talk about the free speech
thing in a sort of broader sense yeah
because I'm sort of in on it now you
know several the other you know sam
harris is obviously added in joe rogan
if you're going to talk to in a couple
days and so many of us are in on this
but you got thrust into it in September
in a sort of very high-profile way now
there's all these videos that people can
see of you going to schools and being
shouted down and as you said really
eloquently 10 minutes or so ago that it
really all comes down to this this
ability to exchange information and
exchange ideas and I could not believe
anything on this earth more than that
that that is what that's the only way
out of any of this stuff how does this
all feel for you right now how do you
feel about being so intimately your life
is involved in this and you it's so
obvious the way the passion comes
through and the emotion all that but
this is just sort of what you've become
it's it's good it's crazy yeah I mean I
don't know what to make of it and I
don't know what to do about it
it's as simple as that at the moment
because my life has shifted so
dramatically for a variety of reasons I
wake up I do what I need to do that day
and then I do the same thing the next
day you know it's I've got some longer
plans than that this biblical lecture
series for example which starts on May
16th and I'm going to do 12 lectures I
don't know how far I'll get but I'll get
as far as I can get because I in the
lectures I'm not going to be telling
people what I know I'm going to be
figuring things out which is what I like
to do when I lecture write it or talk I
don't have a prepackaged doctrine
precisely or like there's structure but
I'm trying to unfold it continually and
differentiate it make it more
comprehensive always that's that's my
aim rather than to to maintain its
current structure that's what I want to
do with these biblical lectures but back
to your point I don't know what to make
of it I don't know sometimes I think
this morning I thought I woke up early
in the morning I thought well maybe
you're just a crank you know you're a
university professor you have these
crazy ideas about mythology then believe
me in in my departments no one ever
thinks about mythology no one ever
thinks about religious phenomenology
like that's just not there even
psychoanalysis in Experimental
Psychology is pushing it you know so
so that that realm of ideas makes me
very much an outsider in my field
although although I have done a lot of
strict empirical science right so that's
how I can stay in the stay in the game
but I think well maybe you're just a
crank you know you have these crazy
ideas now you made a splash on YouTube
you've got this bias population that's
rooting for you but it's just smoke and
mirrors and I think well you know I
don't think so but but I'm by no means
so certain of myself that I I would
claim you know certitude around that
issue yeah but not at all not not in the
least and the notoriety I think is I
suppose in some Fame it's it's a
peculiar thing for me to deal with
I mean I'm I am actually a very private
person I don't talk about myself very
much with anyone generally speaking I'm
interested in ideas clearly obviously
yeah but and then there's the other
issue which is for months and even still
now I do not get to make a mistake right
if I make a mistake while I'm speaking
then or had I made a mistake in the 500
hours of video lectures they're all
online the fact that I became notorious
among certain crowds would have done me
in they would have found something yeah
I'm glad you mentioned that because I
that was where I wanted to kind of get
with this that now you you have all this
lifetime's worth of work you've now hit
a chord that obviously is resonating you
have a patreon bear that's very
successful audience member of my show
can basically create with an IndieGoGo
that they did for you or a Kickstarter
to help you with the grant uh well that
was as relevant Andy and rebel media
people yes yes okay so uh but basically
they funded a lot of some workers yeah
so did yeah my point is with I'm not
trying to make it about the money my
point is yeah it's resonating but yeah
is resonating but as someone that wasn't
in the public eye for a long time right
you've got all these hours worth of
stuff out there we know that people are
just sitting there waiting for man you
see Petersen said what you forgot to say
one word and that sense
and now we can pin him yeah I know there
and it'll deconstruct everything else
that he said do you consciously have to
be aware of that or absolutely not just
consciously you know I have people who
are watching what I'm doing in in the
non paranoid sense yeah sure there's
that thing - yeah you know my friends
yeah and they watch and then we have a
talk and they tell me what they think I
did wrong and then I try not to do it
again you know so the one thing my
father always tells me this he says I
talk too much the interviews and that's
true and and plus told me that many
times but last time we talked he told me
that he didn't think I could do anything
about it
and I think that's probably I don't
think I've ever been able to do anything
about it since I was like - right so
well I can tell you about being on this
side of the interview and interview with
an interviewee who knows what he's
saying it has things to say is that's
what makes this fun well that's good and
now again I have someone here and I feel
like I'm like I have to like pull it out
of them but when someone just comes in
and they're overflowing with passion and
information and curiosity that's that's
basically as good as it get are you
feeling that we have some good allies
right now that maybe when when this
whole thing happened in September and
I'm sure there'll be questions related
to it in a few minutes that you were
sort of like a bounty hunter in this
well that's what kind of where I'm at
with all this that I felt very kind of
alone in there yeah there was just a few
of us but now I see these people coming
out and not only that but when I go
speak at universities and I'm sure when
you do as well even though you get you
get protested more than I do maybe I'm
doing something wrong that that the kids
are coming out there going yeah this
[ __ ] yeah see it it's real we have
to fight it that we are getting some
real support right now in a special way
that I think even four months ago people
were not showing yes well I mean one of
the things that's kept me both
reasonably secure and also reasonably
confident let's say that I wasn't making
a terrible mistake
is the feedback that I've received from
the public no I get no hate mail mm-hm
none zero I've got maybe three since
September that's it yes really you
be really hiding your email address well
yeah you think so yeah thanks away but I
mean I'm getting so many emails I can't
keep up by any stretch of the
imagination but they're all they're all
positive and many of them are lengthy
you know hundreds of words heartfelt
yeah so that's amazing and then of
course in October so the press encounter
that came out strongly in my favor once
they looked into what I was saying and
so that was really helpful and all of
that public pressure and the press
pressure encouraged the university or
allowed the university let's say that's
better
allowed the university to back off
because they were getting a lot of
pressure from the SJW types you know
because they're very well organized and
so you know they had a petition against
me and told me I was making the campus
into an unsafe space and all of that and
for those that don't know basically the
the premise of your talk was that you
didn't want to use these gender pronouns
that have become so insane and and and I
think actually oppressive to how we
function as humans that that's the crux
of it right yeah so next thing you knew
you said something that I think most
people basically agree with that's not
really rooted in bigotry or any of that
kind of stuff but basically right after
that suddenly you were the you were the
bad guy yes never having been the bad
guy
yes exactly well I said that I believe
that those words didn't perform the
function that the activists claimed for
them and that they were the linguistic
vanguard of the postmodern Marxists who
I detest and I'm not using their
language and I detest them for multiple
reasons one is their failure to learn
from history the fact that true Marxist
regimes of course they would dispute
that but I think the evidence is clear
true Marxist regimes have been
staggeringly murderous and the
postmodern ethos abandons all
responsibility and is unit dimensional
and I think it's based on both ignorant
and resentment with resentment probably
coming first and so and I I understand
why the ideas are unfolding and I'm not
going to be a part of that and I don't
care because there isn't anything that I
care about more with the possible
exception of my family then
not playing that game because I think
it's terrible game and I think we're
going to pay for it in a big way we're
already paying for it I think the
universities I think the humanities are
done yeah it feels like it's done and
that's why when when you came on my
radar and as I said suddenly I find
there are months where suddenly a
zillion people will all say at once this
is the person to talk to you in this and
that's what it was for for you in
September
what I liked is that you said I will not
give an inch here and I had that sort of
become a theme with some of the guests
that I've talked to about not giving
this monster anymore food that the
second you give it an inch it's not done
with the inch now it wants a foot no
it's a meter that wants a mile and I
thought that sort of and I guess maybe
that's why they're so against you
because you won't even play in their
game where so many of us out of guilt or
whatever else it is wanting to be liked
who knows we kind of play that game but
you refuse to I think I think it's a
really admirable place to be yeah well
admirable or crazy but it doesn't matter
I guess to some degree because I because
what I've been thinking about led me to
those conclusions and I didn't come by
that randomly by any stretch of the
imagination
and so yeah cuz I've been wondering what
happened right because so what some
professor makes a video you know at
midnight to clarify some things about an
obscure Canadian adhesive legislation
who cares right but I think and so I've
been thinking why it exploded and I
think that I took a general issue that's
somewhat unspoken somewhat spoken but a
lot unspoken and I made it very concrete
and I think in order to make something
real that's what you do all the time you
take the abstract and you make it
concrete right you make it real you in
your actions and then that pushes it to
a to the point in some sense of
confrontation of reality it's like you
have your position I have mine I'm
willing to play out my position to the
end that's a test of belief I suppose or
at least of conviction
then the question is are your
convictions founded on anything of value
and I think that part of the reason to
that this hasn't just gone away is
because people came to my youtube
channel because of the political
material but that isn't why they stayed
hmm they stayed to watch the
psychological material which was an
explanation of why a very long
explanation of why of the thinking
underneath my particular stance yeah and
that's very c1 you know you talked about
going to these crowds and seeing the
positive response you're getting from
young people see what I see that's so
cool and really unbelievable in some
senses first of all my audiences are
almost all men 90% probably in life and
that's interesting because the men are
bailing out of the humanities like mad
right so they're they're
female-dominated to or increasingly
female dominate to a great degree all I
talked to them about rut essentially is
speaking the truth and adopting
responsibility
those are hard things to ask of people
right it's not that's not some picnic in
the park man that's tough and it's so
interesting to see the young guys and
not so young - yeah their eyes light up
you know it's so interesting well it's
always interesting to see people's eyes
light up there's a little flash of
insight you know and it helped me work
out this proposition that the meaning in
your life is proportional to the
responsibility that you take and that's
it that's interesting because that's way
different than well here's some more
rights man you know that'll help you out
know like I know powerful stuff that's
take something in your life and believe
in it and build around that that's stake
your life on it yeah that's a beautiful
all right we could do this for hours and
hours we're gonna take a two-minute
break I'll refill your water again and
then we're gonna do a live Q&A how does
that sound sounds good all right guys
we'll be back in two minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back guys uh we are
going to do a live Q&A with dr. Jordan
Peterson we just did a little over an
hour together we could have done we
could have triple the Rogen show right
there we could've done 14 hours uh but
we did about an hour there but I want to
do it at about an hour of QA for you
guys uh dr. Peterson has been kind
enough to stick around he's got about an
hour so let's just get right to it and
we've already got a zillion questions so
we're doing this on super chat on
YouTube because that cleans up a little
bit of the the chat mess over there and
we're giving preferential treatment to
anyone that is on patreon whatever level
you are supporting us at and we've
already got a ton of great questions hi
Dave and dr. Peterson I just wanted to
say thanks to both of you for keeping up
the fight of free of freedom of speech
and believing that we all have a right
to speak also happy Cinco de drink oh I
mean Cinco de Mayo that's not a question
but will you be having margaritas later
no no more I do not drink
no you don't drink okay well I don't
recently I'll have two for you all right
all right that okay so here we go do you
think that a more traditionalist
approach to religion can be detrimental
to the progression of science so that's
interesting because you're saying that
that religion is sort of a necessary
underpinning of this but can it also
take away from just the pure scientific
method well it's not self-evident that
the relationship between science and
religion historically was as you know
dimensional as it's generally portrayed
I mean science did emerge in the midst
of a Christian society and so the
pressure from the religious side was not
sufficient to stop it from occurring and
it was Nietzsche's idea that without
Christianity and its emphasis on truth
at all costs that science would have
never come about and so in nature's
notion in some sense was that
Christianity had promoted the idea of
truth as the embodiment of logos as the
embodiment of God in the world so to
speak and then that sense of
truthfulness got so hyper developed that
it then branched out into science but
also went under the metaphysical
foundations of the church itself and
to take it apart but so science has a
tremendous emphasis on truth there's a
belief that truth is redeeming even
among scientists because otherwise why
do it's that's the metaphysics of
science why are we doing science well
this is why young related science to
alchemy the alchemists wanted to produce
a substance that would transmute metal
into gold it would give everyone eternal
life and it would ensure health well
that is what we're doing as scientists
right that's there's a dream you see how
we're locked in a dream the dream is is
that the truthful empirical analysis of
the material world will further our
movement to paradise that's the dream
otherwise why do it yeah well so then
without that underlying dream then why
do it yeah and this is basically the
Pinocchio story that you laid out so LSN
we spoke all right here's another one
for super chat what do you think of the
joke of identifying as an attack
helicopter and why the left cannot see
their own ridiculous this even faced
with such strong sarcasm they claim to
have sensitive feelings but they seem to
applause the sense of shame I think
there's a lot there well I think that
that that is too blunt a piece of
sarcasm I think because it indicates
such a distance from the from the
problem that it's easy just to write it
off especially after it's been seen
repeated times right okay so remove the
attack helicopter yeah it's a blunt
trauma yeah well I think it polarized
like I'm not complaining about it I get
the point
you know it's satire fine good but as a
as a gesture to initiate it's not going
to get realization it's not gonna work
no not it's it's not enough to work
clearly it's not enough to work yeah so
but you know more power to satire as far
as I'm concerned yeah what do you what
do you think about that idea that the
left has lost the idea of shame I think
it's more lost the idea of humor yeah
you know it's just dying a slow death
yeah well that's really a bad thing
because comedians are like artists they
tell the truth yeah well three lawyers
I've been saying lately and when I'm
doing these speaking gigs I'm doing a
lot more stand-up again because
is not even that I wanted to but it's
like they're dragging me back yeah
because it's become so he relates all
right let's jump over to uh oh this is a
great one on patreon as a teacher
am i complicit in regressive leftist
dogma if I'm too scared to risk social
suicide this is a great well because it
transcends everything right I get this
from people that someone will say I'm a
janitor and I don't want to say what I
think at work you're like it's it's not
just teachers and professors and I could
eat academics it's everybody that is
there silence I think they think is now
becoming a problem which I'm glad to
hear but what do you think well
Solzhenitsyn Alexander Solzhenitsyn said
something like the worst thing that a
human being can do can have happen to
them is to sacrifice their god-given
soul for hope for human dogma and so
yeah yeah I mean he had a right to say
that you know and so I would say that's
something to have a discussion with
yourself about you know your if you
you're going to come to hate going to
work you're going to come to hate your
colleagues you're going to turn your
soul into more of a worm than it already
is because by not allowing your impetus
towards truth to manifest itself then
you train yourself to be hidden and
deceitful
I mean look in the Soviet Union people
lied about everything all the time to
everyone including their family members
hmm right so how does that start it
doesn't people don't go from telling the
truth to be dishonest in one leap it's
like they it's sins of omission that
begins it and the sin of omission is
well I really should say something but I
won't it's fine it's like you're you're
that much weaker then and there that
much stronger and so what that means is
the next time you're called forth to
speak you'll be 95 percent is likely to
and then it'll be 90 percent is likely
to and by the time you make a thousand
decisions like that it's oh no matter
what happens you won't say anything yeah
and then then you're done yeah and I
always say to these kids when they say
well what how can I get them up I just
created a YouTube channel I'm some guy
to create a YouTube channel you're some
guy that put you know that had an
academic background but you put your
beliefs into action and we just need we
just need more people that will stand up
and say what they believe this is a good
one on super chat what do you believe
what belief or thought is the most
dangerous to homosapians survival as a
species existence is corrupt and
therefore should be eradicated that's
that's the dog doctrine of Goethe's
mephistopheles in Faust so the devil
looks at the world and says like Ivan in
The Brothers Karamazov he says there's
too much suffering it's it's a it's a
it's a parody it's a catastrophe
it's not worth it we should just end it
that's the most dangerous thought partly
because you can make a very strong case
for it
is there an end to this regressive ism
and the antifoam of menteur will they
continue to destroy free speech and free
thought with no boundaries I suspect you
wouldn't do what you do if you thought
it was just going to end poorly well the
likelihood that things will end poorly
is always higher than the likelihood
that they will end well because there's
a billion ways for things to end poorly
in like two ways for them to go well
right so I would say it's up in the air
it's a personal one that kind of that
kind of makes some sense in the scheme
of all this what do you think about all
the absurd internet memes about you
roughly speaking can you see all this
stuff like well I think we got the
answer with your immediate laugh right
well yes it's it's absurd it's it's it's
which is also one of the memes because
apparently I'm supposed to say absurd
yeah observe they spelled it correctly a
BZ yeah yeah yeah and so I have these I
have a few characteristic speech habits
apparently which people like to make fun
of but that's fine with me
you know it's good it's good for people
to have a laugh and and and it's done
playfully as far as I'm concerned yeah
and I look at it I look at all this all
of this you know in a pretty detached
way I wouldn't say it's going to my head
at all yeah to me it's just like it's
sir it's it's literally surreal I don't
know what to make of it so it's funny my
father looks at
means all the time and laughs it's like
my kids laugh about it so funny all
right this is an interesting because it
links back to another interview that I
did David Horowitz mentioned that Trump
could actually enforce a sort of
fairness policy in place for public
universities and make them balance out
leftists with an equal amount of
conservative professors do you view this
basically as a solution because the
leftist ideology is taking over our
universities I mean that that was part
at least seem self-evident to me that
that ideology has just taken root there
and they've done studies right it's
something like oh yeah I ninety percent
of the professor's identify with the
left yeah well in the humanities it's
more than that yeah yeah um I don't know
if the universities can be salvaged in
their present form
there's too many catastrophes be setting
them simultaneously student load depth
student debt load administrative
overhead this cult-like behavior on the
part of the humanities which is the core
of the universities because the
humanities go the universities go and
then this technological revolution
that's making information much more
freely available like that's a lot of
challenges it's and too many as far as
I'm concerned I suspect that the
universities are going to radically
alter in the next 10 years now that's
not much of a prediction because
everything is going to radically alter
in the next 10 years but no I don't
think I don't think that you can enforce
something like that because what will
happen is it it sounds simple to do that
but it's not it's really really really
complicated first of all people would
have to cooperate and they won't so you
know just because you make an adjustment
at the top doesn't mean that the wheels
necessarily turn in the direction you're
trying to make them turn right and it
would also be using identity politics to
solve identity politics if you said well
we have to have 50 percent conservators
even though I would prefer it more of a
diversity of thought you'd be using
their logic all right and how do you
measure concern how conservative is
conservative enough and and no right
it's not tenable okay this is
interesting I just want to ask how clean
dr. Peterson's room is and also to say
thanks for everything you've done
they've never encountered such a
powerful truth a fighter for truth and
decency and bravery I think that's an
interesting question how clean is your
well at the moment it could use some
ordering I'll tell you but I do believe
as I've said in many of my lectures that
your local circumstances reflect your
state of mind and part of the reason my
room is somewhat chaotic now there's -
we did a fair number of renovations and
got to my room in terms of ordering at
last
yeah but also I can't keep up and so
it's evident when you walk into my room
because there's piles of things that
need to be sorted out in too many places
and I'm acutely aware of that but there
are times when there are so many things
demanding your attention that it's
actually not possible to it to either
figure out what to attend to properly
just how how do you make a hierarchy out
of it yeah and like I have no idea how
many public speaking engagements to
engage in you know I have no idea I've
got way more invitations that I know
what to do with right and I don't like
saying no to people but but it's taxing
to let the traveling and it's expensive
and anyways it's not that clean right
not today Karina sometimes a pile does
pile up okay
patreon why do you think it's important
to conceive of motivational states slash
drives as subpersonalities rather than
as cognitive circuits what are the
upstream and downstream consequences of
this characterization that are so
significant that that's a heavy one oh
well the reason their personalities is
because they're alive and and alive
things have a personality and so the sub
parts of you are also alive you know if
I if we ablated a part of your brain a
big part say there'd still be a your
personality it would be a
lower-resolution you right and then we
took more off it'd be a lower-resolution
you but unless you were dead there would
still be something something that was a
personality and the personality is not
only how you think about the world it's
it's how you perceive the world and so
for example if you're hungry a
motivational state then the world
manifests itself to you as a place to
obtain for
and that's driven by the hypothalamic
circuit and into yuna dimentional
personality it has a goal it has a way
of looking at the world it has arguments
at its disposal and rationales
it has the capacity to suppress other
competitors it's it's a live thing and
it's it's just about it's a much better
it's much more accurate a better
metaphor because if you're hungry there
are behaviors that are primed they're
not driven exactly although there's a
drive like element to that as the
motivation increases
we're not deterministic machines in that
sense so we're not driven precisely
because driven implies determinism but
we're very good and flexible at making
our way through a complex environment
your hunger has thoughts it has emotions
it has a viewpoint it has arguments it
has everything a personality has except
that it's like a cyclops mythologically
speaking it's got one eye right it's
look in one way yeah but but if you get
that thing revved up enough like it it
dominates that's why often motivational
states in in old societies were gods
like Mars the God of War it's like that
could overtake you and why was it a God
well because it wasn't just in you it
wasn't just in me it was in everyone all
the time and even in animals so the god
ideas like it's an abstraction it's so
there's this there's this force whatever
that's not a bad metaphor yeah that's
that never dies and it's manifest
everywhere at the same time that you're
subject to that's the Greek idea right
thank you say I like this you're giving
me Greek mythology yeah and the little
Star Wars at the same time now where
you're fully giving me everything okay
back to super chat is there any truth to
social psychology is view of race such
as out-group favoritism or prejudice it
seems that social psychologies worldview
is seen through an SJW lens that's
similar to sociology that's interesting
I think social I think social psychology
is a very corrupt discipline I thought
that for years and in fact the social
psychologists themselves have been
arguing about that bitterly for about
the last three years because many of
their primary studies aren't replicating
there's a big attempt to
locate them I think that now that
doesn't mean that all social psychology
is is worthless it isn't by any stretch
of the imagination but the discipline
isn't well oriented is for its to
careerist in my estimation and it's it
is informed by like an
anti-establishment ethos I know that's
an old term but it's correct you know so
with with the political work for example
it's almost always the case that
conservatism is being put forth as
something that requires explanation
whereas liberalism well obviously that's
that's the water that the fish is
swimming and of course you should be
liberal and yeah I don't have anything
against liberals by the way of course
you should be liberal with what the
hell's up with those conservatives it's
like well that's that's no way to run
the show you know it's it not from a
scientific perspective it's like you you
should first of all make the
presupposition that thinking
biologically that these are both they're
valid modes of being they're being
expressed differently for different
purposes now that's how I look at yeah
that's what we're losing now why
everyone loves to just demonize the hell
out of everybody
I'm not even viewing these the opposite
opinion as something that could remotely
be legit well the thing that's
interesting about conservatives say by
and large is they're good at running
organizations they're good at
algorithmic implementation and you need
people like that man because someone's
got to do that and it's necessary to
duty that those conservatives are what
would you say they're they're impelled
by duty to a tremendous degree and duty
is do what you should do now and if
you're an entrepreneur you need a bunch
of people around like that because they
make your business work you think of the
idea so you're the liberal because the
Liberals are more that liberals are more
creative technically speaking they're
higher in openness so they they make
better entrepreneurs but they can't
without that conscientiousness they
can't implement and so there's this
tension which is why we have this
political tension between let's call it
originality and innovation and structure
instability well obviously there's a
tension there but innovation without
implementation is just fantasy and
implementation without innovation falls
behind
so you have to have a dialogue to write
to get one working with the other you
have to I love that that's exactly what
I'm trying to do here maybe you need the
idea idea guy to have the other guy who
can actually make some things happen we
sort of touched on this but I think it's
an interesting question can I be
Christian and not believe in oh the
questions just changed on me uh I lost
it there sorry
the basic question was can I be
Christian and not believe in in the
myths and just and believe in sort of
learned wisdom instead it depends it
depends on what you mean by believe
people it's not like believing something
is one thing it's a bunch of things and
the existentialists for example were the
first to point out that perhaps the best
marker of belief is action because you
act out things and you may not even be
aware of why you act them out you just
act them out you imitated them you're
socialized so you're reflecting a
pattern that everyone taught you the
question is where did that pattern come
from well it came from the same process
that produced these religious
underpinnings you reflect those in your
behavior so modern Western people say
well I are not Christian anymore it's
like well yes you are it you act out the
Christian ethos you don't know you're
doing that because do you don't know
what you're doing I mean I know you do
but in a more comprehensive sense you
don't you don't understand where all
your behaviors your customs your
traditions
all of what we consider social norms you
don't know where they came from but you
act them out so there's a belief that's
implicit in that now then you might say
well I don't believe the representation
of that belief well all right so you're
criticizing you're still acting it out
so you're it isn't that you don't
believe precisely it's that you're
confused and no wonder because the
modern world is in the state of
confusion and partly what I'm trying to
do is to rectify that confusion by
pointing out how the myths map on to the
behaviors and why so that they can be
revitalized to some degree this is
interesting this from patreon what do
you think the effect of free and widely
available pornography is having on young
people especially men in our society at
this time well I
think it it's like Treasure Island in in
Pinocchio it's all pleasure with no
responsibilities
that's deadening its its parasitical in
a sense and I don't mean that I'm not
making a value judgment I mean it's no
wonder the young guys are caught up in
this because it's an unbelievably
powerful technology it drove the
development of the Internet let's not
forget right so it taps into one
viciously primordial motivation and so
these guys are being blasted by what
biologists call super stimuli all the
time so imagine that there's a
biological stimulus that has an effect
on you and then you can magnify it and
the typical porn actress not the
amateurs but the professionals have
their sexually provocative physical
elements exaggerated and so men are very
visual in terms of their sexual
processing and so you know the guys are
pulled into it and they're pulled into
it also by curiosity but I think that
ethically it's a it's a it's it's not
good it's not good it's it's an easy out
that's the other thing you know is what
you should be doing is going out and
finding someone to have a relationship
with and if you can gratify yourself
with no transformation but let's say you
can't find someone well then you might
say that's an indication you should
change it is in fact an indication that
you should change because what better
indication are you going to get then
that no one wants to be intimate with
you right it's the ultimate rejection
and that's partly why men are terrified
of it and I understand that and I
understand the mgt o/w guys you know who
are who are just recommending that men
don't enter into long-term permanent
relationships with women I understand
where they're coming from although I
called them pathetic weasels awhile back
I shouldn't have done that
see that's where I said yeah you're
worried about it yeah yeah yeah once you
say some well they're providing a lot of
young guys who who need a kick to go out
there right they're actually giving them
the bed they're you're giving them a
rationale yeah I've seen this have very
detrimental effects on a number of
people yeah all
ready and partly in my clinical practice
because these guys the young guys who
aren't successful they're looking for a
reason why women are terrible because
otherwise they have to think well
they're just not presentable which is
what they do have to think because
that's almost the definition of
presentable right so and then the mgt
o/w guys give them a rationale you know
we're in a gyno centric world and
females have got control and they'll
like wipe you out if they have the
opportunity it's like well some females
will do that to some guys some of the
time and sometimes it's brutal I've had
clients who've been dragged through the
court systems and just ruined and I I
was unable to help them I did everything
I could to maneuver and negotiate and
plan and strategize so carefully to get
them to do everything right and it
didn't help I mean the court systems can
be absolutely brutal to men it's awful
yeah that's really interesting so the
guys that are taking the easy out on
that so to speak in disconnecting from
having those relationships in a way the
same it's just a different out that that
porn is replacing for that that human
connection to it so that's fascinating
all right this is interesting this was a
$200 question on on super chat
now's Hermeticism Hermes thought
anthropos the true vessel of alchemy
being man
the Magnum plus ma Atwood would it
surprise you that I read all this
midsummer only months before your videos
went viral
please extrapolate on the terms above
and leave the New Age [ __ ] out of it
all right so there's a lot there what
can you take from a question like that
let's go you want to go with one of
these but okay well sure ting Hermes
we're going to call him mercury for ever
curious for the sake of argument okay so
I'm going to lay this out a little bit
this is no chemical idea so first of all
if you mix mercury with or that has gold
in it the mercury will pick up the gold
so that's interesting okay so that's
that's the magic of mercury is that it
will it will take the gold out of the
raw material hmm okay so now remember at
the beginning of the conversation I said
that if you're going to read Macbeth the
idea is to extract out from it a valid
and implementable philosophy behavioral
pattern
well that's extracting the gold out from
that from that from the ore okay so now
mercurius is also the winged messenger
of the gods and so he flips around now
that's what your attention does you see
because your attention is always being
pulled in different ways by forces that
you don't understand this is the
fundamental insight of psychoanalysis
and probably its most terrifying insight
is that your very attention is
controlled by forces that you do not
understand now the ancient people
considered those forces it's more
complex than this but they consider them
gods because the gods could direct your
attention and so now how does Mercurius
as the winged messenger of the gods okay
so now let's say the gods will call them
unconscious forces or we'll call them
gods they're trying to orient you in a
particular direction for some reason
they do that by making things more vivid
for you than they would otherwise be
those things attract your attention now
interesting this is just the same way
you describe the point actress is a
second yes yes yes it's that it's a very
similar mechanism that's a very but but
some of that's your choice because you
aim at something and then things
manifest themselves but some of that's
the result of these unconscious forces
illuminating parts of the world and
darkening other parts will they
illuminate your path
well you could say that all those
unconscious forces imagine those as the
pantheon of the gods and they're trying
to send you a message about how to act
well they do that by sending mercurius
who flips around and he's the thing that
glimmers that captures your attention
okay now the Union idea it's a brilliant
idea is that the integration of all
these unconscious elements their
integration into a into a into a
functional unit then manifests itself in
your field of experience as an
interesting pathway and if you take that
interesting pathway you unfold and so
it's it's the it's the manner in which
the instinct that drives you to
self-realization interacts with you and
so for young he would say well that's
the self young thought of the self as a
four dimensional entity that that
extended across time and space that was
the totality of you and he thought that
that totality which was ineffable it's
it's your full potential
or something like that manifested itself
in cross sections of time as that which
grabbed your interest to them it's an
amazing it's absolutely amazing idea you
know now now in them think about it this
way a book will grip you what does that
mean that it gripped you it means it had
it had you in its palm well what had you
in its palm you know these are things
and you're inspired by it
well inspired by what what does that
even mean it means all of a sudden a new
path has illuminated itself for you and
the Greek idea would be that the panoply
of gods had sent a messenger Mercurius
who flits around ya and he captured your
attention and pulled you down that is in
that book and ironically you could burn
that book in two seconds and it would be
gone but the path would be forever
illuminated yes which is really a
beautiful thing
what are the longer this is from patreon
what are the long-term effects of
diversity policies and equity targets on
campus I mean we've sort of hit this oh
but basically it's deciding what happens
okay here's our company collapses and
I've watched this because you know one
of the things the lefties don't really
give capitalism credit for is its
capacity to destroy itself continually
so there is a 1% but it's it transforms
across time the fact of the 1% remains
the same but the contents of the 1%
transform okay so well what happens
let's say a company has a bad quarter
and they announced layoffs and then
they're not going to take the time to
sort through everybody properly by merit
they're going to do it fairly which
means easily and without too much
controversy and they're just going to
arbitrarily select people to layoff well
what happens in most institutions a
small proportion of the people do the
vast majority of their genuine work that
that's a law called prices law so the
square root of the number of people
involved do half the work so if you took
a discipline if science and there was a
hundred people in that subspecialty ten
of them would write 50% of the
publications okay those are people
typically who have options right because
they're on top of it
they're smart they are conscientious
they're there they're working 70 hours a
week they can get another gig they can
get another gig real fast and maybe one
that pays more and so as soon as the
thing gets shaky it's like the good
people away because why wouldn't they
and so and you don't need to knock the
quality of an institution down very much
before that starts to perpetuate itself
you know they say a people hire a people
but B people hire C people and in my
opinion that's correct I mean if you're
not let's say a higher order intellect
for whatever that's worth and I'm no
worshipper of the intellect by the way
you are unable to evaluate someone who
is you'll just think that there's well
maybe something wrong with them or or
they'll be threatening to you or you
won't be able to talk to them and you're
going to go for someone who's at your
level or lower and and you believe me it
doesn't take very long for that to have
true effects it makes people cynical too
because well with the research chairs in
Canada for example the Canada Research
Chair which of these very prestigious
named chairs set up by the federal
government across Canada in universities
to pull international talent into Canada
of the highest calibre well they just
announced yesterday that they put on
they're not going to award they're
threatening the universities with
withholding the function unless they
came up come up with diversity targets
for the Canadian chairs based on gender
and the you know the typical offenders
primarily gender and race well as soon
as some of these get awarded on the
basis of gender and race the validity of
the chair is eradicated and everyone
gets cynical it's like well and even
let's say someone deserving gets just
for the sake of argument yeah well
everyone's still thinking okay you know
eh why did you get that position and be
if the plum positions are awarded on
dimensions that have nothing to do with
merit then I'm an idiot for acting
meritoriously because it's difficult you
know it's not and the other thing that's
so funny is that the federal government
for example is they're treating these
chairs like they're rewards for good
behavior right so everybody should have
access to those rewards but that isn't
how they should be concept
july's they should be conceptualized as
okay well we found a productive person
and we're going to set it up to extract
every cent of value we can out of that
person before they die right for the
benefit of society it's like we want you
to work yourself to death yeah and
here's some money you know thank you
it's not it's not
well everyone deserves a chance it that
isn't it it's it's the productivity that
counts not the consumption it's the
productivity that counts and so well
it's such a backwards way of looking at
things right because you're rotting the
very institution that you're supposedly
trying to build well that's the
supposedly part because we go back to
the post modernists right we can do that
we can debate that for the yesterday
this is interesting from super chat is
there any word or phrase that should
remain unspoken does offending or
hurting one's feelings with your speech
require any tangible punishment or
public shaming that's good enough so I
suspect for the latter half that you
certainly don't agree with that but is
there any word or phrase let's focus
there that should remain unsaid you've
always been like that you're like that
now and you're never going to change
that's conversation killer yeah that is
a conversation killer yeah yeah that's
the heavy artillery in a fighter in a
fight between spouses for example right
that's a that's a killer yes that's
fighting words because where do you go
from there yeah um look up in a public
exchange of ideas you put up with what
you get you know I mean there's lots of
forms of speech that I regard as
detestable
that I think in fact are detestable and
if people put those points of view
forward then they should be chastised in
the proper manner now we already have
laws for some things you can't insight
someone to a crime for example and so
there are restrictions on what you can
say although there haven't been there
hasn't been a push to say what you have
to say until these bills in Canada which
is another reason I objected to them the
fact that well in this Linfield lecture
I gave just a week or two ago I was
talking about what I regard is the
ethical constraints surrounding free
speech it's like free speech should
serve the
truth that if you're going to engage in
free speech you have a responsibility a
corresponding responsibility which is to
say what you believe to be true and that
doesn't mean what will further your
agenda in a practical manner right the
truth is a different thing than that
so they're not saying that those other
people can't are not at all but that
you're missing the sort of societal yeah
we have to be punishments and rewards
associated with the public discussion
because how otherwise would you evaluate
it yeah so you know some of that can be
contempt some of it can be shamed better
if it's a thought-out argument
indicating why this is a bad way of
looking at the world or an incomplete
way I think that's more it has
longer-term effect because it educates
people mm-hmm so all right let's jump
back to patreon for a second
what would you say Trump's IQ really is
does 160 seem reasonable no this will be
quoted and no 160s really really high
yeah I mean the typical the smart person
that you're likely to meet in your life
has an IQ of around 145 yeah 160 is
getting pretty damn rare and Trump's old
an IQ goes down with age fluid IQ
although crystalized IQ either stays the
same or goes up slightly so he isn't the
problem solver or the learner that he
was when he was 20 no one no one is if
you're in good physical shape that helps
a lot his IQ is clearly well above
average um I don't know
and he's done complex things in his life
and a lot of them and that indicates
that there's something to him you know
and he hasn't been successful just in
one domain he's been successful in
multiple complex domains each of which
were quite difficult it's very difficult
to be a reality TV star that's
successful right it's very difficult to
work in the construction business and
especially on large projects and I know
he's had his economic ups and downs but
he stayed in the game for a long time
very stressful he's very stress
resistant so he's known he's no dummy
and I mean it's nice to always think
that your political opponent is just
stupid but he's done too many complex
things for me to assume that he's
somehow if he wasn't smart he couldn't
have done those things yeah I'm glad
you're acknowledging that because when I
see the people that are in hysteric mode
and just saying he's this evil nut bag
who doesn't know what he's doing a lot
of stuff it just seems like such a lazy
way of thinking about it you don't have
to like any of the things he may not
like the way he speaks or any of that
but the idea that somehow this is a dumb
person I think it's discounting of just
the way humans have to work this is
interesting from superjet to you but he
also won the presidency right with a
completely original campaign and it's
like and with or without spending much
money it's like okay is he lucky because
is that what you're saying is just lucky
right well I don't think it was just
luck it was it was at least maybe well
it looked at least to some degree like
courage maybe it was just blind throwing
caution to the wind you know I don't
know if he ever expected that he could
possibly win yeah and I'm sure you'd
argue you probably had a little sign to
do with all those things that maybe
there was some cards but that he also
surrounded himself with people who maybe
understood politics more than he did
well he could on the sign and can also
obviously read a crowd yeah because he
was appealing to crowds and that that
was partly because he didn't he didn't I
think try to say what he thought now you
could criticize what he thought and
that's fine but but he also didn't
prepare the same speed that you know he
didn't prepare a speech and then deliver
the same one everywhere which i think is
I really find that rather reprehensible
for people to do that yeah because
they're they're parroting themselves or
someone else writes their speeches which
is something I can't even imagine I
can't I can't for what we do I can't
even fathom it actually I think this is
really interesting
do you have any thoughts or insights on
how a gay man can handle himself one
after figuring out that he's gay to
place himself as a man and at the same
time different from most men including
his father I think is sort of
interesting because I think because
you've talked about gender pronouns
somehow somehow people think that you're
somehow anti-gay or something I've never
seen any evidence of that but I think
this gets to well I think so one of the
things let's take the LGBT community at
large let's say okay what are they
trying to do
well one out answer is they're trying to
not be discriminated against
and the other answer is and maybe it's
the same thing they want to be included
in the norm okay I'm going to assume the
louder because maybe that's why the
marriage issue came up all right the
thing is you can't be in the center in
the norm and on the margin at the same
time now there's utility in being in on
the margin you want to be a drag queen
you're likely going to be on the margin
and that's where your customers are
that's where your draw power is that's
where your satire is that's where your
entertainment is on the margin you want
to move to the center mm you have to go
along with the ethic of the center and
so what I would say is well if if
marriage is the ideal then if it's worth
pursuing as a right then it seems to me
to come with the commensurate
responsibilities and so to the degree
that being in a monogamous long term
emotionally fulfilling honest
relationship constitutes the central
core of marriage then it seems to me
that you're obligated to do that unless
you want to be on the margin and I'd
like there's as I said it's not like
there's no reason to be on the margin
this freedom out there you know you're
you're you're not normal
you're like the avant-garde in art yeah
but do you want to be normal that's the
question I had a really interesting
discussion with Milo about this because
he said that the gay community basically
is giving up all of the things that made
them so edgy and funny and interesting
and irreverent all that because they're
trading it for normal yeah and I think
that's that's sort of what you're
talking exactly I think it's a great
conversation there's a lot of richness
there that we should well the
alternative is to blow apart the center
so it doesn't mean anything but that's a
bad idea that yeah I think it should be
that's bad idea um is there any truth to
social psychology viewers view of race
such as out-group favoritism prejudice
oh did we do this one already we did
something we did sign close to that I
mean there is truth in your go vision
group while in-group favoritism I mean
of course people rave or their in-group
that's what you that's what it means to
love your family
and you can't love everyone equally you
know I mean you can respond to another
person as if they're valuable in a
personal encounter yeah but you're
you're the center of your experience and
then you have your close people and of
course you're going to favor them but we
think there was something wrong with you
if you didn't now if you're going to
favor them you're going to favor other
people less yeah so what do you want to
just give up close relationships right
in the name of equality no I think would
be the well hopefully yeah will you now
the some of the [ __ ] posters have gotten
in here so here we go will you support
the liberation of the oppressed people
of Pakistan haha
no they have to they have to liberate
themselves ah so I've been blind Lee
supporting these people I want them to
be free but you want it to come from
within Irish yes I would think that
would be that's the way to be truly not
oppressed yeah oh this is interesting
from superjet is there a chance for a
new religion that provides all the
lessons but doesn't lie about the
reality so really kind of molding both
of the things that you're talking about
oh it's an that's an open question
it better be I mean part of the reason
I'm doing these biblical lectures is and
I'm going to start with the discussion
like this it's like well we've got this
book and you know it's a problematic
thing and we've been working on it for a
long time and if if it isn't worth
anything then we've got nothing and we
better not have nothing because that's
not a good thing to have and so maybe
there's something to it so let's move
forward with that hope that's the idea
no you can dispute my claim that the
mythological stories let's say in the in
in the judeo-christian tradition are
somehow foundational I don't believe
that you can dispute that claim
reasonably merely because of the way
things unfolded across history I mean
you can say that the Enlightenment was
the opposite but I don't believe that
but you can make that case we can't
throw the baby out with the bathwater
and so I'm trying to figure out what I
want to do is make an empirical case for
the biblical stories and leave the
metaphysical case hanging you know that
there is an interesting empirical case
even to be made for the metaphysics for
example we know that mystical
experiences can be reliably induced in
the lab for example you can use
psilocybin to do that and no one knows
how to account for that and they're not
trivial the same thing is true of DMA
and people might say well those are
hallucinogens and can you consider those
a valid form of experience an answer to
that is we don't know there is a long
term follow-up study of hallucinogen
users four or five years ago looked at
250,000 people and found that as a
population they were healthier than the
people who hadn't experimented in many
many ways including psychologically they
even had fewer flashbacks you know and
I've known a number of people with with
psilocybin in particular who told me in
various contexts that one experience
without straightened out their lives in
some important way I know it's also been
used as a very successful aid to the
cessation of smoking by that researchers
down at Johns Hopkins I believe so
so anyways back to the question every
generation has to rescue their dead
father from the from the abyss and so
that's what we need to do that's what
I'm trying to do and and we better be
able to do it because without a central
narrative we will fractionate and we'll
be weak and that will be the end of us
because weak people do not survive in
this world well this is a good segue
then to this one this is from patron
what are your thoughts on kids being
over prescribed drugs for a DD it's a
tout it's just like we're taking the
dream away from them well yok panksepp
who recently died unfortunately um he's
done stellar work on that and he's he is
to use amphetamines on rats and you
might say well rat isn't a very good
model for a person but I can tell you
that a rat is a much better model for a
person then your stupid idea of other
person so you can get a long way with
rats and he found that ADHD medication
suppresses the the inclination to play
it does heighten the inclination to pay
focused attention to whatever is being
attended to that moment but it
suppresses the play instinct now
children need to play they really really
really need to play because when you
grow up all you're doing is playing with
people right and so if you don't learn
that really at a young age and if you
don't become super proficient in it
you're you're just not in a good place
it the reason the fact that so many boys
need a DA a DHD medication is a much
more serious indictment of the education
system than it is an indication of the
prevalence of ADHD in the general
population there was also a large-scale
study done in Quebec just a few years
ago showing that there were no long term
positive effects of using amphetamine
amphetamines on kids really yeah yeah I
mean they're do more on that topic in
general I really like this question this
is super chat could technological or
physical exit say through living
off-grid be a strategy for those who see
the troubles facing the west can it
complement the the quote-unquote voice
of truth speakers today in society or
does it leave them and our values more
vulnerable
the basic premise being if people just
said enough of this nonsense and just
kind of got off Oh would that ultimately
be good or does that leave the few of us
you know people like you that are out
there doing this does that just leave us
exposed and hanging and well I think
that it seems to me that there's great
danger in centralized systems you know
and we've we've centralized some of our
systems you know that old adage too big
to fail it's exactly wrong right because
what it is is so big it has to fail
that's the story of the Tower of Babel
by the way it's so big it had to fail
right everything fractionated and went
its own way that's what happens when
things get too big maybe that's what's
happening to the EEC right because there
has to be once something is too big you
have no relationship between the bottom
where you are in the top so it's like
God has disappeared in some sense you've
got no who's has allegiance to the EEC
well no one it's like abstract workings
of some sky demon you know that's
distant
there's no identity there's no way to be
there and there's a way to be with
national identity at least to some
degree in a wait a second I lost track
of the question what was I so basically
give that would getting off grill yes
yeah um it's reasonable I think for
people to to try to move away from vast
centralized systems at least to some
degree I mean I it's interesting to me
what Tesla is doing with the batteries
and the solar power you know because a
system that isn't so centralized has
fewer single points of failure and we
could really use that the distributed
power system would be a nice thing as
far as I'm concerned so I think there's
some utility and trying to make yourself
not too dependent on too much
centralized provision if you want to go
live by yourself off the grid like
there's some people whose temperament
inclines them to do that they're usually
introverted and disagreeable so they
don't they're not touchy-feely types
right and they don't want a lot of
social contact and so you know more
power to you as far as I'm concerned
maybe you're right yeah I don't know
well for the purpose of this we're going
to stay on the grid all right so guys
here's what we're going to do Jordan's
gonna stick around has to leave here in
four minutes we're going to do a final
piece of this as a one more thing for
patreon subscribers only then then
you're free to wander the universe how
does that fit so that doesn't sound good
okay thank you guys for watching this
was a pleasure I like doing these things
live I think the energy was great I
think dr. Peterson of course and and if
you all remember on patreon you'll catch
this next segment should be up I think
by the end of today all right all right
[Music]
you